so we're multiplying matrix a here by
vector w and they ask us what is a times
w so let me get my scratch pad out and
let's think about this
so we have matrix a times vector w so
just as a reminder aw
and i'll write it in bold right over
here a
w
a
and i could write it either as a vector
like that or i could bold that as well
a w it's a lowercase four vector
uppercase four matrix this is the same
thing
as matrix a as matrix a times
times
vector w
vector w that same color
which is the same thing this is matrix a
so it's
a is
5 5 2
times vector w w is the vector
is the vector
4 3.
so we have a matrix we have a matrix
with 2 rows and 3 columns so it is a 2
by 3 matrix times a vector and this is a
column vector it is three rows in one
column so you could view this as a three
by one matrix and so deciding whether
this is even a valid operation is just
like multiplying two matrices you can
view this column vector as really just a
three by one matrix and the only way
that matrix multiplication is defined is
if the columns in this matrix is equal
to is equal to the rows in this matrix
and we see that is the case this fir or
this vector this matrix matrix a has
three columns one two three and this and
vector w has exactly three rows so
matrix multiplication or matrix times
vector multiplication is defined here
and the way that we're going to do it
we're going to end up with a
two
by one
you could call it a two by one matrix
it's going to have two rows in one
column or you could view it as a two or
as a column vector when you have two
rows and one and one column but either
way let's actually think about how we
would compute it so it's going to have
two rows and one column and i'm going to
give a lot of space so that we can
actually do the calculation
so the top entry right over here
we're going to get the row information
from this
from our first matrix and then the
column information there's only one
column here we're going to get that from
this matrix or this vector whatever you
want to call it so we're going to have 0
times 3
0 times 3 plus 3 times 4
plus 3 times 4
plus 5 times 3 plus 5 times 3.
now the second entry right over here is
going to be
is going to be the second row here
essentially the dot product of that with
this vector and if you don't know what
the dot product is i'm essentially about
to do that it's going to be phi you take
each corresponding term take their
product and then add up everything
together so you have five times three
five times three
plus five times four
five times four
plus two times three
two times three and this is going to
simplify to
this is going to simplify to
this top term this is a zero this is 12
plus 15 which is 27
and then the second term this is 15
plus 20
plus 6. so to see this is 35 plus 6 is
41. so it's a column vector 2 rows 27
and 41. now let's input that 27 and 41
so we get
and here we can put a 41
and check our answer and we got it right